today was a total fail you were the
cause I had to wear an ugly dirty dress
my tries too long so I had many clothes
today was a total fail
today was a total
I wore that dress do you even have a
clean t-shirt you told me I look goofy
and I look like a mess today was a total
fail
today was a total value find the dried
my dress hour tonight
every spot of me Borgata stood still
today was it so fair
they're all alike
send summer garments
the children
so how many of you had to leave the
house with wet clothes because your
dryer took you long to dry your clothes
hmm yeah how many of you leave a comment
if you're one of them and who I am
that's why I wrote this song